the Border bill it's not really a border
Bill they're calling it a border
security bill but it is a disaster it's
basically funding for Ukraine to the
$260 billion funding for Israel and $20
billion for amnesty I guess the bill
basically just codifies exactly what is
the Biden Administration is doing it it
creates an easier path for Asylum
Seekers quote unquote to be granted
Asylum and to be given work permits this
was the play it was obvious Joe Biden
screws up the border and basically
creates a mess then when Republicans
start complaining Joe Biden says I need
I need a bill then when they put
together a bill giving Biden everything
he wants and destroying the Border they
call it a security bill so when
Republicans in the house not the Senate
oppose it the media will run rampant
screaming the Republicans are against
their own bill that was the narrative
and that's exactly what's happening